monsieur bonjour un merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france à leurs
maîtres en dessous vous êtes médecin à
quel point la situation sanitaire et est
inquiétant en france et dans l'hôpital
dans lequel vous exercez
oui bonjour la situation est inquiétante
parce qu'effectivement elle a pris une
ampleur mais comme au niveau mondial en
termes de contamination de personne donc
vous l'avez bien remarqué on a on a
dépassé à plusieurs reprises et 300000
le cas détectés mais attention la
situation au niveau d'un hôpital est un
peu différente en ce sens que il ya une
certaine stabilité je ne peux pas
m'avancer et dire que nous avons atteint
le plateau puisque c'est un petit peu
disparate selon les régions il n'empêche
que depuis une semaine depuis une
semaine on observe une disons stagnation
des cas entrer en réanimation même si
les réanimations sont assez utilisé
certaines sont à 70 % de leur capacité
d'autres un petit peu moins dont un peu
plus donc ceci ne veut pas dire qu'il
n'ya pas eu un impact très négatif sur
d'autres maladies
d'autres problèmes beaucoup de patients
sont déprogrammés et ce n'est pas donc
une situation intenable pour décider car
des maladies qui mériteraient justement
de programmer les interventions
chirurgicales et donc pour lesquels on
n'a pas la possibilité d'aller de
disposer de lits de réanimation donc la
situation reste importante on a pas fini
avec la vague delta et voilà que la
vague omikron s'est superposée on ne
sait pas si la gravité va être la même
il n'empêche que la au nombre de cas
détectés elle est quand même énorme
voire dix fois supérieur au précédent un
mythe n 1 vous venez d'entendre ce
médecin selon laquelle la situation
sanitaire et est inquiétant pour le
moment est ce que selon vous ça doit
légitimer le pass vaccinale qui sera
bientôt instaurer
je prends tout le contraire parce que je
pense évidemment que le pas de l'axial
bâlois mais aussi d'acheter mais surtout
d'un bon
sens sur le pastel la libye et à
certains
autres sans avoir de comptes à rendre
finalement puisque ce sont les personnes
non vaccinées aujourd'hui qui se fond
qui se font tester en plus il ya des
études très sérieuses qui démontre
maintenant que au mois de décembre par
exemple et une étude de la drees deux
tiers des décès des ducs au vide sont
des personnes totalement vacciner
l'institut robert koch en allemagne qui
est le pendant allemand de la haute
autorité de santé
96% des personnes infectées à aux micros
sont des personnes vaccinées et on voit
bien d'ailleurs dans les débats récents
inquiète même des questions qui se
posent sur les effets de ce vaccin en
termes de facilitation de l'infection et
donc je crois que le sujet sanitaire en
fait n'est absolument pas réglé par le
bac signale au delà même de la
discrimination qu'il entraîne j'entends
bien le problème tension à l'hôpital
c'est un prénom qui est malheureusement
une chronique et il faut rappeler
toujours le marteler qu en 2020 en
pleine pandémie le gouvernement à la
supprimer encore 5700 leach à l'hôpital
alors ce qu'audi de nos gouvernements
c'est que ce pas sanitaires se passe
vaccinale aujourd'hui ce n'est pas parce
que la vaccination protègent de la
contamination va bien que maintenant
fait vacciner contracté le covin mais
que la vaccination empêche les formes
graves du coc vide imad comme sow est ce
que c'est bien cela
absolument oui ça a été trouvé par
manque d'études sur le terrain donc les
études cliniques et des études sur le
quai rhin dans différents pays il est
totalement certain que la vaccination à
un schéma complet de deux ou trois doses
protège des formes graves et du décès
c'est à dire que des personnes même avec
des comorbidités
vaccinés avec un schéma complet sont
capables de résister à des formes graves
et donc ne vont pas subir une
hospitalisation en réanimation une
intubation et ne vont pas à voir les
conséquences
sur le long terme de ces
hospitalisations qui vendent des
séquelles assez graves pour les
personnes qui sont
monopolisés qui monopolisent donc non
seulement un lit d'hospitalisation mais
qui reste des semaines en
hospitalisation et des mois après en
rééducation ça c'est un phénomène
fondamental et c'est tout ça qu'on
essaie d'éviter avec les vis d'un
évitement aussi de l'engouement des fans
de réanimation ça c'est important il
faut le reconnaître il ya des données
parfaitement établie et surtout sur le
terrain
alors rémy tu es dans le bassin
sanitaire pas se vaccine assez pour
contre 1 ont poussé les gens à la
vaccination bien sûr pourquoi selon vous
emmanuel macron et son gouvernement
n'ont pas réussi à convaincre à
communiquer là dessus sur les bienfaits
de la vaccination
l'idée selon laquelle la pédagogie
suffirait à convaincre 100% la
vaccination de la population
vaccinée est une idée
qui qui s'inquiètent injuste sur le plan
purement intellectuelle puisque c'est
faire chi des arguments solides qu'on
certaines théories de la population pour
s'interroger sur le mac ça lorsque
jean-marc sabbatique et un professeur de
médecine directeur de recherche au cnrs
publié un papier dans lequel il montre
que les rappels répétées d'un même
produit a fortiori arn messagers peuvent
contribuer à dérégler l'immunité à
favoriser peut-être sur le long terme
des maladies auto immunes ou des cancers
il est tout à fait sain et il est tout à
fait normal de s'interroger et c'est pas
en faisant la pédagogie qu'on va lever
ces doutes qu'on va lever ces
inquiétudes comme les inquiétudes sur la
question des effets secondaires le
bundestag lire le bundestag allemand le
parlement allemand vient de demander le
lancement d'une enquête indépendante sur
la surmortalité observée en allemagne en
2021 et qui n'est pas lié au co vide
voilà et donc les questions des
parlementaires allemands c'est pourquoi
il ya t'il cette surmortalité en 2000 21
s'agit-il des effets secondaires de la
vaccination
s'agit-il des maladies qui n'ont pas été
prises en charge par ce que l'on exclut
aussi les personnes non vaccinées de
l'hôpital moi j'ai dans mon entourage
des personnes atteintes de cancer
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne peuvent plus
concrètement se faire soigner ou alors à
la discrétion d'un chef de service qui
va être un peu plus accommodant sur sur
les règles mais encore une fois si on
raisonne simplement d'un point de vue de
la santé publique se passe vaccinale n'a
absolument aucun sens mais de quand
soirée métal le disais tout à l'heure on
parle également de non sens scientifique
qu'avez vous à leur répondre
alors tout d'abord s'il ya bien un
produit de santé un produit
d'utilisation humaine qui a fait l'objet
d'études scientifiques sérieuses c'est
bien ces derniers vaccins nous avons et
donc il faut il faut bien dire les
choses comme elles sont y'a aucune étude
halte sur le long terme puisque nous
n'avons pas eu le temps d'évaluer sur
des années un des effets sur la réponse
immunitaire donc attention quand on
introduit et c'est naturel quand on
introduit un boudin d'un agent pathogène
ou un agent pathogène entier et nous
sommes confrontés naturellement depuis
la nuit des temps dans l'environnement
nous avons des tonnes de pathogènes que
nous inhalons que nous avalons et que
nos équipes hommes meurent prépare la
peau tous et toutes ces particules petit
gourou plus gosses vont déclencher une
réponse immunitaire et c'est la réponse
immunitaire qui va déterminer là la
réponse est là la manifestation clinique
de la maladie alors quand il s'agit d'un
vaccin il s'agit en l'occurrence d'une
partie du pathogène ou du pathogène
entier comme pas donc le vaccin chinois
thiais le virus même atténuée au des
petits morceaux du virus qui sont
utilisées pour déclencher cette réponse
immunitaire alors s'il ya bien et je
répète un produit de santé qui a été
testé qui ont été testées sur des
milliards de personnes soit à l'heure
actuelle c'est bien ces vaccins en tic
au vide alors je veux bien on connaît
peur que je veux bien qu'on a une peur
irrationnelle c'est tout à fait
compréhensible c'est tout à fait naturel
mais pourquoi nous en tant que citoyen
on va réagir contre quelque chose qui a
fait la preuve qu'ils étaient analyser
étudier scientifiquement est évalué par
des personnes sérieuses par des comités
indépendants sérieux par des agences des
médicaments et pourquoi je vais réagir
et assimilés ça à une réponse socio
anthropologique négative contre des
états ou contre des sociétés alors que
moi-même je vais pas m'interroger sur le
contenu par exemple du du bar-tabac
d'une d'une cigarette je vais pas me
poser la question sur le contenu d'un
shampooing que je vais utiliser sur le
contenu d'un déodorant que je vais
utiliser dans hot docs comme je les
mange et je ne vais pas me poser la
question sur tout un tas de produits qui
ne sont jamais analysé qui ne font
jamais l'objet dès qu'ils sont produits
par des industriels et que nous
consommons au quotidien je m'interroge
jamais sur les ondes de téléphones
portables je ne manquerai jamais sont
tous ces trucs là et en fait je
m'interroge maintenant parce que c'est
l'objet qui cristallise les
mécontentements sociaux et tous mes
peurs ancestrales et je vais les
cristallisé pour aller dire non le
vaccin alors que attention nous sommes
mon second délit avec un schéma vaccinal
ce n'est pas le seul élément nous avons
des médicaments qui vont commencer à
apparaître qu'ils vont nous aider ça ça
va permettre de nous construire un
consensus et à voir les deux prochaines
années il m comme ça je suis désolé on
est vraiment pressé par le temps à rémi
tales je voulais c'est le droit de
répondre un très très rapidement c'est
vrai ya pas une confusion aujourd'hui
entre le sanitaire et le politique
en tout cas moi ce que je vois c'est que
le vaccin que vit 19 fonctionne
tellement bien que à nouveau la dre sens
et pas théorie du complot plan comme
l'adresse une institution officielle
montre qu'en décembre 2021 deux tiers
des personnes décédées du comique 19 été
vaccinées que l'ia chu de marseille
vient de prouver que la charge virale
des personnes atteintes du variant delta
était plus importante lorsqu'elles
étaient vaccinés lorsqu'elles n'étaient
pas vaccinés et que vous avez
aujourd'hui 300 milles plus de 300000
contamination quotidienne en france
alors je
vraiment là pour ne pas voir qu'il ya un
problème avec ce qu'on nous a présentés
comme le vaccin entre parenthèses le
l'un des pionniers du vaccin arn
messagers pour berne à londres parle
aujourd'hui de techno techno fascisme
vous avez des des sommités en la matière
qui regarde ce qui se passe avec un
énorme et froid et donc cette peur elle
est tout sauf rationnelle quant au
traitement alors oui effectivement il ya
des traitements il ya même des
traitements anciens qui marche très bien
des traitements repositionner moi j'ai
eu comme idée une forme a d'ailleurs
assez embêtant tu me suis soigné avec de
l'ivermectine comme des centaines de
milliers de français l'ont fait et ils
ont noté eux mêmes l'amélioration
significative de leur état je comprends
que ça ne soit pas un business model
très rentable pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique qui veut produire des
nouvelles molécules parce qu'évidemment
le prix de vente n'est pas le même mais
encore une fois si on s'intéresse à la
santé et l instant et uniquement il
existe aujourd'hui des façons de limiter
la propagation du commis 19 au japon on
a mis fin en partie avec les mii grâce à
l'ivermectine ça a été le cas aussi omar
astral en oeuvre ou pourrait multiplier
les exemples mais ce n'est pas le but de
ce gouvernement le gouvernement tire
prétexte d'une crise sanitaire pour
asseoir un projet politique comme
d'ailleurs ça toujours là toujours été
le cas avec l'épidémie dans l'histoire
donc c'est pas moi qui confondent
sanitaires et politiques c'est le
gouvernement et ceux qui prétendent agir
au nom de la santé les français rémi
tanor merci à vous êtes co fondateur du
collectif peuple libre il m'a donc en
dessous vous êtes médecin infectiologue
à l'hôpital antoine béclère à clamart à
messieurs on l'a bien compris deux avis
complètement différent tout cas merci
d'avoir été avec mon direct sur rt
france